No you're a big kid is there such thing
as like growing up who wants to grow up
that's when you really need advice i'm
ferrell and i'm told to tell you right
now that i give great advice
i don't know how true that is at josh
densey boy accidentally super like my
lecturer on tinder and now she keeps
messaging me what should i do
are you kidding do it Wheatland of
course maybe she can teach you something
at ash kitchen
i've always been fairly conservative
with my fashion choices but i want to
win something bold and different what
advice would you give to lose closeted
fashionista wear it with confidence as
long as you believe that it's for you
then it'll work at just what nadir I was
thinking of getting a tattoo done after
getting yours laser do you think I
should hold off absolutely lasering it
hurts it it is like zap zap zap zap zap
zap zap zap zap zap zap snap man it
hurts
at gonzo 90 I kiss my mate sister at a
house body a couple of weeks ago and I
really like her he's super protective of
her what should I do
you have to earn his trust so then he'll
be cool about it you know just be a good
dude maybe he'll come around
you just never know but you got to start
off by being a good dude at the Santa
house 21 everyone tells me I can't sing
but I know I have a great voice how do I
block out the haters sing louder soft
amazing shouts turn to the lad Bible I
dropped my phone
yay
[Music]